digamos que estás en una especie de
concurso y te está yendo súper bien y
has llegado al punto en el que te van a
regalar unas vacaciones ahora hay tres
posibles lugares donde podrían suceder
estas fabulosas vacaciones podrías ir a
unas playas increíbles en una isla
o podrías ir a esquiar
o podrías ir a acampar a algún bosque
acampar ahora éstas no son todas las
posibilidades porque también tenemos que
considerar la duración de las vacaciones
nos pueden regalar unas vacaciones de un
solo día o nos pueden regalar unas
vacaciones de dos días o nos pueden
regalar unas vacaciones de tres días y
los del concurso simplemente van a tomar
unas de estas vacaciones al azar y nos
las van a regalar aunque ahí nos puede
tocar que nos regalen unas vacaciones de
esquiar dos días o nos puede tocar
acampar un día o cualquiera de estas
posibilidades y la primera pregunta que
quiero hacer es cuáles son todos los
posibles resultados aunque cuál es el
espacio muestral cuál es el conjunto de
posibles resultados del cual vamos a
escoger aleatoriamente tu paquete de
vacaciones bueno
el espacio muestra lo que podemos hacer
es una tabla
y como podrás observar mientras iba
diciendo cuáles eran todas las
posibilidades fui construyendo la tabla
lo único que nos falta es terminar de
poner las líneas
vamos a poner los posibles resultados
únicamente con las iniciales puede ser
que te regalen unas vacaciones de un
solo día en la isla aunque tenemos aquí
un día en las playas de una isla o puede
ser que te regalen unas vacaciones de
dos días en la isla o que hay dos días
en la isla pero bueno sabes que vamos a
hacerlo diferente aquí en toda esta
columna nos van a regalar vacaciones de
un solo día aunque esta es una vacación
de un día un día en esta columna están
las vacaciones que duran dos días
dos días dos días en esta columna son
vacaciones de tres días
de vacaciones y luego viendo las filas
en esta fila son vacaciones en las
playas de una isla así es que aquí ya
tenemos estos dos estas son unas
vacaciones de tres días en una isla en
esta fila tenemos vacaciones en los que
te van a llevar a una montaña esquiar
aunque puede ser de un día dos días o
tres días y finalmente en la última fila
están las vacaciones en las que te
llevan a acampar a un bosque que puede
ser que te lleven a acampar en un bosque
un día dos días o tres días y así de
rápido y fácil acabamos de terminar de
construir el espacio muestral aquí están
todos los posibles resultados que son 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y digamos que en
realidad esto está escrito en una hoja
de papel lo cortan en estos cuadrados
los doblan para que no veas que tienen
escrito los meten en un bote y te hacen
escoger al azar
uno de estos papelitos cuando obviamente
no puedes ver que tienen escritos estos
papelitos eso sí cómo estás escogiendo
al azar alguno de estos viajes podemos
suponer que vas a escoger cualquiera de
estos viajes con la misma probabilidad
que hoy porque no puedes ver cuál de los
viajes estas es cogiendo y si suponemos
eso que cualquiera de estos posibles
resultados tienen la misma probabilidad
de ser escogido por tu mano entonces ya
podemos hacer más cosas como calcular
algunas probabilidades ok lo que estamos
haciendo es suponer que todos estos
resultados son x probables ahora digamos
que tú vives en un lugar muy frío y lo
último que quieres hacer es ir a meterte
en medio de la nieve esquiando y
entonces te gustaría saber cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener por lo menos 2
días de vacaciones para poder
disfrutarlo pero dos días de vacaciones
lejos de la nieve que te gustaría
encontrar cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener por lo menos
los
- dos días de vacaciones dos días pero
lejos de la nieve
lejos de la
nieve o sea no es que ando ok vas a
escoger al azar alguna de estas nueve
vacaciones sin saber lo que estás
escogiendo y quieres saber cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener unas vacaciones
de por lo menos dos días y que además no
escojas las vacaciones en los que te
llevan a esquiar o sea en medio de la
nieve y bueno estamos suponiendo que el
bosque en el que vas a acampar está muy
lejos de la nieve así es que vamos a
pensar en esto cómo sacar esta
probabilidad tenemos aquí el espacio
muestral y sabemos que cada uno de estos
posibles resultados es x probable
entonces pues vamos a escribir eso por
aquí aunque hoy tenemos nueve posibles
resultados ec y probables ahora cuántos
de ellos satisfacen las condiciones de
este evento nunca hay cuántos de estos
posibles resultados hacen que suceda el
evento de que te vayas por lo menos dos
días de vacaciones lejos
la nieve y con eso de lejos de la nieve
lo único que estás haciendo es excluir a
todas las vacaciones en las que te vas a
ir a esquiar ok pero bueno vamos a
fijarnos en todos los posibles
resultados y vamos a ver cuáles hacen
que suceda este evento a ver por aquí
tenemos un día en la isla pero pues es
un solo día entonces no nos interesa que
hay por aquí tenemos dos días en la isla
y eso lo vamos a circular
ok porque si son por lo menos dos días y
en la isla no hay nieve por aquí tenemos
tres días en la isla también cumple con
las condiciones del evento luego por
aquí todos estos tienen mucha nieve así
es que los tachamos de una vez luego
tenemos un día acampando y no nos
interesa porque queremos dos días o más
aunque luego tenemos dos días acampando
y tres días acampando entonces 4
cuatro de los nueve resultados ec y
probables satisfacen las condiciones de
este evento así es que la probabilidad
de que suceda el evento es cuatro
novenos
así es que tienes una probabilidad de
cuatro novenos de ir a unas vacaciones
de por lo menos dos días lejos de la
nieve ok
espero que te sea útil para la próxima
vez que te encuentres en algún concurso
extraño o algo por el estilo